un passaggio che cerca di camminare
conosciuta è uscito ice scream 3 e del
video venatorio cattivo è tornato è
uscito proprio oggi quindi siamo super
curiosi di vedere che cosa succederà
adesso con il gelataio cattivo è una
storia nuova
un gameplay nuovo c'è anche un armeno
salutarvi ciao ciao ciao spiri
lasciatevi raccoglie un bel mi piace se
volete vedere altri gameplay e se volete
che fini ha potuto ice cream 3 e fa
vista per gli altri giochi volete che
proviamo a giorni i commenti ei prati
via difficoltà normale due bambini sono
stati sono scomparsi in questi giorni se
qualcuno sa qualcosa informate la
polizia velocemente questo c'era scritto
nel giornale quindi l'inizio molto
simile c'è scritto di controllarci
intorno quindi la cameretta bene o male
più o meno uguale tranne lo comprerò
possiamo aprire la porta
questa è chiusa porta giosa però nei nè
scream 1 e 2 non si poteva andare in
giro nella casa ci dispiace destra certo
paura di trovarlo davanti prima o poi
dobbiamo ad aprire qualche porta la
cugina ok io resto qui vedi vedere se
c'è qualcosa da mangiare perché ce n'è
andato lì
ci sono praticamente delle con gli
oggetti di road che sarebbe ice cream
hai bisogno della chiave per uscire 4
dobbiamo trovare la chiave questo il
bagno mi sembra che ci sia nessuna
chiave vediamo qua che figlio si può
ecco la chiave bravo paura che ora ci
sono a rotoli
eccolo sta cantando la sua canzoncina
malefica mi ha detto so che è il leeds e
voglio salvarla e lui dice liszt penso
che ti stai confondendo e lui disse lo
vizza nel
lui dice credo però che so di chi stai
parlando
non mi ricordo i nomi o di tutti i
bambini che catturo ha il coraggio di
affrontarmi ma non sei ciccione
abbastanza sul secondo c'è una soluzione
per questo domani prima bocca abbiamo
fatto mangiare un gelato forza per noi
molto buono collezionato non capisco
perchè l'hai fatto ma chi ti sta
ingrassando all'improvviso ok ciao
ragazze cicciottello di dissezione ora
sensi ci tengo come piace a me io non
vorrà mangiare
[Musica]
ok quindi gli ha dato questo gelato che
forse a dei gelati malefici che fanno
ingrassare per uscire fuori allora c'è
scritto che prima mi devo nascondere
siamo nascosti nella cuccia del cane
vediamo come anche dall'altro degli
altri è scomparso per un vestito a festa
va bene nuovo e qualche bug quindi come
nel primo al secondo cade la mappa però
penso che i voli siano diversi in questo
ice cream quindi sono stufo alcuni non
teniamo per la madre hurley allora
prendi primi previste poi vediamo cosa
mai ci ha road in giro
ok abbiamo preso la mappa la mappa
dobbiamo mettere sempre c'è un codice
devi distruggerlo quindi devi prima a
prendere qualcosa che spara ok abbiamo
preso l'estetica ok a dovevo premere
quel pulsante di non avevo capito allora
apriamo la porta c'è qualcuno a il
bambino di prima che ha fatto ingrassare
la messa nella gabbietta quindi dovremo
salvarlo ci prendiamo la mappa e andiamo
a metterla nel van fa schifo schifo
schifo per a dirlo riguardo ma dietro di
noi tanto lento ho paura che adesso ha
scaricato
[Applauso]
devo nascondermi prima mi ha visto che
mi chiamo pochina promessa
allora i posti nuovi quali sono il circo
shopping center rubò il nuovo quindi il
supermercato la devastazione campeggio
che nuovo lo stesso e anche la stazione
della metro ma questo è il circo sera
anche prima ma ora di lauro modificato
un mulino era il cinema quello che c'è
la primavera circo proviamo andare e
quelle di sì e di coda su pizza in
termini sembra super interessante ma
andiamo alla stazione metro per poi
andare a la battuta ok allora shopping
center diamo vediamo cosa si aspetta
ceniamo nella piscina enorme questione
c'è questo questo centro commerciale
centro commerciale allora apriamo la
porta a ma siamo entrati dentro potuto
che mi sembra quello di stringersi è
vero
a parte di ciò che attengono visto sopra
la scale mobili aiuto io voglio
esplorare i tifosi
lui sta scendendo e noi saliamo
giustamente caprica rigori k questi sono
tutti i negozi a trovare qua allora
dobbiamo trovare degli indizi e
risolvere i puzzle ma questi si possa
una prima prova questo si è aperta
direi proprio di no dov'è sento che
scattiamo scappiamo poi ci sono le scale
se ci sono le scale a ricarica
ricorrente adesso scommettere su medie
ma che tipo uno scivolo tanto lei adesso
sta sopra noi possiamo esplorare un po
sotto vediamo qualche certo che sono
questo questo l'ascensore non mi
convince allora le indie si dice che
dobbiamo entrare nel negozio di minimoto
che forse è quello che si è fatto aprire
prima qui andiamo velocemente andiamo lì
eccolo e questo è questo quindi dobbiamo
cercare di entrare in mezzo non sono
rapporti provo ad abbassarmi clicca hai
bisogno di un oggetto per aprire qua
quindi dobbiamo cercare un oggetto
qualcosa che possa sollevare allora
andiamo alla ricerca tempo dove è finito
ormai per john conoley gli affetti
siccome questo centro commerciale molto
grande
e più facile scappare il mantenersi da
vedere ma vabbè tanto noi siamo più
veloci che la vediamo quest'altra all
ala del centro commerciale questa che
sta assuma che riusciamo a trovare
qualcosa forse dobbiamo trovare una pala
[Musica]
questo ovviamente non sia per nessuna di
queste porte
vediamo o qui c'è un negozio aperto si
trovi un qualcosa fa
no è una vetrina a parlami di te la pena
aprirebbe essere utile come prova a
riaprirla al devo tenere premuta forza
che vedi per chi ha carica così forse
bisogna abbassarsi ad entrare mentre una
sofferta
proviamo dobbiamo trovare un'altra
soluzione vediamo che cosa c'è qui c'è
un oggetto la vedo
il giudizio non c'è spagnolo della
fantastica diceva perché 6 passano così
tanto rumore dobbiamo trovare questo
oggetto dove può essere di aiuto ce
l'hai proprio lì di fronte come faccio
saltare ma scusa ma perché sinistra da
londra della piscina guarda lui cerca di
camminare con un sacchetto
ok allora abbiamo capito che dobbiamo
prima andare da qualche altra parte
perché qua non si riesce andare avanti
abbiamo esplorato non c è il centro
commerciale ma non ci sono questi non
c'è questo oggetto quindi
approfittiamone per andare ad esplorare
un'altra delle nuove aree e magari
scopriamo anche qualcosa in più sulla
teoria di roma e andiamo circo camping
non lo so perché niente restante sarebbe
il campeggio dette tetti che vedete
tutti parlino ci sta guardando maris
dov'è lo sento che canta sono tutti
accampati
ma non c'è nessuno con dentro dove lui
lì sono una cosa che forse riusciamo a
34 è chiuso proviamo qua è chiuso aiuto
o qui bisogna scaldino così un po che
dice sei tu cosa è successo l'altro
giorno come il papa buono cercando di
leggere e tradurre ma è bello perché ho
quindi puoi interagire con gli altri
personaggi perché c'era con la dominano
a segnare
la risposta però non ho fatto in tempo
perché mi ha preso ma non l'ho neanche
visto che arrivava
ok allora bisogna uscire adesso da
questa come nelle nei precedenti dai
così vitale bravissimo e mi appare dalla
cantina faccia qualcosa
le forbici dove starà fuori allora con
le forbici che possiamo fare a tagliare
no guarda questo punto dobbiamo tagliare
con www.go facilissimo per oggi anche di
non essere preso da ros in trappola come
faccio a brevissimo essere professore
rhodri no pronti è ok allora abbiamo
tagliato tutto come bisogna stare di
fronte a me ok
scappiamo andiamo andiamo al circo
stavolta
perché si è così ci abbiamo un'opzione
nuova ok siamo arrivati al sito chi mi
ricordo che c'era anche nel 1 e del 2 ma
vitale dice di no non ricorderà è ancora
le forbici i massi non lo vedo
no non si può correre perché devo andare
così allora saliamo su queste scale si
ok forza è chiusa non avevo capito io
sto e non riuscivo come facevo a
scappare abbiamo solo una vita dai
provato adesso prima di perdere un'altra
vita voglio esplorare gli altri ambienti
isione ha già riparato sotto la porta
che perché glieli ogni volta prende
tutte le precauzioni se tu sei riuscito
a scappare dalla finestra più della
finestra se riesce a scappare dal tetto
ripara il tetto in questo caso riparato
tutta la porta io arrabbiato forse si
arrabbiano trasformando in un unica
trovò in un altro tipo di gelato in un
calcio è questo
una spranga o come si chiama
e per cosa a sputare per aprire un
ministro che la mattonella diceva qui
che avevo bisogno qualcosa
un passaggio crescere io attento casomai
eroe facendo qua
chi siamo ci siamo quasi c'è scritto che
roth sta dormendo e devi cercare di non
fare rumore
ovviamente che ci sono i pezzi di legno
che tu hai fatto che sarà molto
difficile ci svegliamo guarda sopra
aspetta aspetta non aprire perché è
probabile che noi siamo forse era serio
tormenta ma dove siamo
dovremmo essere fuori no se voleste
uscire forza
non so come fare lì sono i resti a firma
del camioncino lui non ne potrà adesso
stanno il camioncino dell'immagine ok
non andiamo andiamo dove non siamo stati
ancora alla stazione metro sono
d'accordo
questo posto fa paura
bellissimo dopo potete iscriversi nei
commenti qual è l'ambiente che vi è
piaciuto milivinti vediamo un po cosa ci
aspetta qua è proprio una stazione buy e
desolata non entrare
c'è scritto che noi entriamo treatment e
pericoloso questa stazione cielo
concorso di portarlo a tanta gente è
pronto qui solo questa ma il genero dai
negozi parzali timo se quasi a me c'era
una cassaforte
no ma no non lo fa aprire mannaggia che
cosa eticamente nasconditi
non lo so come ingressi però tanto non è
qua vicino quindi bene non possiamo fare
niente altro penso ma possiamo solo
nasconderci ma questi dove scappo
c'è un pezzo di binario buttato lì che
aiuta ma qui c'e la porta hai capito
no molto benvenuto dover ott
spero che non sia venendo qua trimenti
sono in c'è qualcosa qui vedi che cos'è
monopattino forse questo che dobbiamo
fare noi infatti è un prezzo personale
auguri roader li dobbiamo portare questo
al centro commerciale sì per alzare la
saracinesca o no sono spider riders
adesso scappa scappa aiuto non so se te
può esplorare qualcos'altro qui però
siccome ora scappando la velocità del
nord è meglio che tornano nel furgoncino
dov'era il fork su cui scanu che non mi
stia seguendo ancora ok torniamo
studiato alla shopping o la sciocchezza
e attenta non lo vedo beh perché molto
da tanta coltello devi prima aprire la
porta si è grandissima
ti devi abbassare vai spero che il
rodano riscontra che parte con lui ma
che bella molto un wow cosa scegliamo
allora un po'di abbiglia ma a quel punto
ma è una moto già accesa per cento
ok posso andare in moto quindi nuovo
piano è che tu sei pericolosa
che cosa sono questi con questo premio e
indietro con questo valeva ok allora di
notte il comando hai un po che forse si
è così pagina a quanto già in giro
ok forse era meglio se la guidavo io
troppo lenta solamente se andavamo a
piedi lo stretto
sicuramente sarà più facile scappare da
roma guidare questa cosa qui così
lentamente ad ora dobbiamo tornare
dovremmo forse tornare nel camioncino
qualche parte per la facciamo entrare
quello modo un ottimo aiuto mi sta
sbattendo scendiamo le scale mobili alla
volta proviamo
chiediamo è complicatissimo da gestire e
coordinare più facile davanti quando
quando vai in avanti e più facile quando
vai in retromarcia la super veloce che
succede se bloccato è rimasto bloccato
12 scalare dobbiamo andare da un'altra
parte no a ribalta ii e prendi la ci
proviamo questo lo posso portare così
andiamo nel camioncino subito vado più
veloce riesco riesco a muovermi più
velocemente a piedi con la moto in mano
che sono amburghesi servirà qualcosa
questo mondo dove possiamo usarla circo
possiamo fare siamo stati io direi di
tornare al pomeriggio perché non abbiamo
ascoltato
bene che dobbiamo fare qualcosa lì
perché c'era anche una persona nascosta
nei cespugli è vero stiamo parlando con
la persona che in cui mi raccomando
sempre con attenzione
forse il motorino va dato a quella
persona nascosta per farla scappare vero
non ci avevo pensato aiuto bisogno
incastrato riuscirà l'italia a
sopravvivere difficilissimo penso che
ritorno il mediatore di te come titolo
di man
abbiamo solo una vita devi assolutamente
evitarlo ma secondo me non è qui ha
visto tutti ha detto che non ne va
ancora male è giusto così difficile è
peggio di gray sembra che con questo 3
si è diventato ancora più ok andiamo
però che non arriverà
eccola qua la bambina siamo su cosa
nascosta ma perché non mi pare scappare
farò dei raggi highroad che si fa a
parlare con la ragazzina però senza
dargli le spalle perché sono così road
del primo addosso non lo so serve una
risposta quasi ed eccolo lì abbiamo
detto ho cliccato una risposta che le ha
dato fastidio
la verità che mio fratello charlie
ecco allora penso di aver capito che non
dove comunque a dare a quella ragazzina
non dobbiamo interagire quella ragazzina
ci sta solo facendo perdere tempo ei sei
tu cos'è successo all'altro giorno
come ti è venuto in mente di saltare su
quel su quel camioncino la verità è che
stavo cercando mio fratello charlie non
lo so perché non l'ho visto da un po di
giorni ok ciao è praticamente una
conversazione infinita che se scegli la
risposta sbagliata di far iniziare
daccapo nel frattempo arriva lo scafo
scamosciato dove scappo ciascuno
maledizione adesso per l'ente dall'altro
nel frattempo io ho ancora la moto
perfetta dobbiamo tornare al furgoncino
è scappare
ce la farà lei a seguirci sì ma perché è
vita intera seguendo dove dobbiamo
andare
andiamo a noli e dove ci cattura andiamo
nel network woodsen ok devo avere la
chiave
ritorniamo c ecco allora che non abbiamo
visto tanto che succede questa è la
storia di rod questo e lui da bambino
dicembre del 55 giorno tragico ieri un è
successo qualcosa di tragico
però se tu vivi qui da sei a casa deve
ritornare da lei tu continui a non
capire per favore il ritorno dal ritorno
da lei
tutto questo è una spiegazione a roth ti
lascio questa lettera che è stata
scritta da tua madre
roth sullivan
c'è una storia interessante dietro non
ho fatto in tempo a leggere perché
velocissimo non è il giornale sarà
scritto che c'è stato un incidente con
un camion
forse vi un camion dei gelati quindi
forse il padre di rod ha investito
qualcuno qualcosa dobbiamo riuscire a
scoprirlo andando avanti nella storia se
riusciamo a sopravvivere dove dovremmo
andare circa esplorare e jason lee
schiavo ma perché non va in giro in moto
dopo era chiuso non puoi andare a scappa
no
si no
ma no un'altra vita il vino ma anche
sotto a si può riaprire ceco detto
perché si muovono ok praticamente che
sognava spostare tutte le cose cliccare
un sacco di volte in ogni cosa fino a
spostarla piano piano l'ora x
con un po di pazienza un bel po di
pazienza sarà risaliamo e dobbiamo
andare dove dovremmo andare adesso la
moto l'abbiamo persa stragista se no
dobbiamo tornare a prendere rod sta
dormendo tanto io direi di andare
nuovamente alla stazione metro primo
svizzero qualcuno non abbiamo visitato
bene
[Applauso]
ok che qui ci capiamo questa teoria un
po provato a questa parte che sa che era
chiuso
allora stavamo entrando nella stazione
metro ma purtroppo il gioco accresciuto
forse perché loro non rilasciato da
pochissimo quindi ancora qualche errore
comunque lasciate un mi piace se volete
che continuiamo a giocare insieme a voi
scrivete sicure i vostri consigli perché
io sono troppo curiosa di vedere cosa ha
scritto la madre di rotzo in quella
lettera e del sapere di più sulla sua
storia quindi lasciate un bel mi piace e
ora vi lasciamo con quattro case linee
su cui cliccare per vedere i nostri
altri video applicato su quella che
preferite e buona visione